Jetzt erreicht uns die nächste Horrormeldung
aus der Antarktis: NASA-Wissenschaftler haben
mehrere Risse entdeckt, die sich durch das
sogenannte Brunt-Schelfeis arbeiten.
Fest steht: Wenn sich die beiden entscheidenden
Risse erreichen, bricht ein gigantischer Eisberg
ab.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen - es handelt
sich um eine Eismasse mit einer Fläche von
1700 Quadratkilometern - also fast doppelt
so groß wie Berlin.
Und insgesamt hat die Antarktis inzwischen
eine unfassbare Menge Eis verloren.
Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Auch, wenn wir auf den ersten Blick nicht
direkt etwas mit den Land- und Meeresgebiete
rund um den Südpol zu tun haben, könnten
die Prozesse dort auch für uns unangenehme
Folgen haben - und das schon ziemlich bald.
Studien zufolge würde der globale Meeresspiegel
im Worst-Case - nämlich dann, wenn das gesamte
Antarktis-Eis schmelzen würde - um unglaubliche
58 Meter ansteigen!
Eine weltweite Katastrophe - und eben nicht
nur für die Küstengebiete dieser Erde.
Bisher ging man davon aus, dass vor allem
der Westen des Kontinents vom Abschmelzen
betroffen ist.
Anfang des Jahres (2019) hatten wir bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction beispielsweise über einen
riesigen und äußerst mysteriösen Hohlraum
im sogenannten Thwaites-Gletscher berichtet.
Ein zehn Kilometer langer und 350 Meter hoher
Hohlraum, der wohl ursprünglich mal mit 14
Milliarden Tonnen Eis gefüllt war.
Alleine das Abschmelzen des Thwaites-Gletschers
könnte den weltweiten Meeresspiegel um sage
und schreibe 65 Zentimeter anheben.
Verschiedene Forschungsteams haben in der
jüngeren Zeit aber immer wieder gezeigt,
dass auch die Ostantarktis wohl deutlich mehr
Eis verliert als man bislang dachte.
Und auch das sogenannte Brunt-Schelfeis, um
das es bei dem aktuellen Alarm der NASA geht,
liegt im östlichen Bereich.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
berichten nämlich jetzt von Rissen in den
Eismassen, die dazu führen könnten, dass
ein gewaltiger Eisberg ins östliche Weddellmeer
treibt.
Das zeigen aktuelle Satellitenaufnahmen.
Für Beunruhigung sorgt vor allem ein neuer
Riss mit dem Namen “Chasm 1”, der bislang
als stabil galt.
Doch im Jahr 2012 begann er zu wachsen und
zwar in nördliche Richtung.
Pro Jahr wächst Chasm 1 gerade um ganze vier
Kilometer im Jahr.
Das Problem dabei: Somit ist er nur noch wenige
Kilometer vom sogenannten Halloween-Riss entfernt,
der vor 2,5 Jahren um Halloween entdeckt wurde
und sich in östlicher Richtung verlängert.
Klar ist: Wenn sich die beiden Risse des Brunt-Schelfeises
erreichen, spaltet sich ein gigantisches Stück
Eis ab.
Die Kanten des Schelfeises hatten sich den
Beobachtungen zufolge seit 1915 in nur geringer
Geschwindigkeit verändert.
Dabei ist das sogenannte “Kalben”, also
das Abspalten der Eisberge vom Schelfeis,
laut der Fachleute ein durchaus normaler Vorgang.
Doch die Veränderungen und Eisverluste in
der Antarktis haben laut NASA in den vergangenen
Jahren rasant an Geschwindigkeit zugelegt
- und das ist eine wirklich alarmierende Erkenntnis!
Vor zwei Jahren brach der Eisberg “A68”
an der Antarktischen Halbinsel ab - mit sage
und schreibe 5800 Quadratkilometern ein wirklich
gigantischer Brocken und fast sieben Mal so
groß wie Berlin!
Die Region hatte sich vorher erwärmt und
Forschungsteams hatten Schmelzwasser-Tümpel
beobachtet.
Diese hatten die Abbruch damals wohl beschleunigt.
Bezüglich der aktuellen Veränderungen in
der Ostantarktis ist noch nicht wirklich viel
mit eindeutiger Sicherheit zu sagen.
Fest steht derzeit nur: Sobald sich die beiden
Risse im Brunt-Schelfeis erreichen, entsteht
ein Eisberg mit einer Fläche von etwa 1700
Quadratkilometern - und damit knapp doppelt
so groß wie Berlin.
Doch wann genau dies passiert, können die
NASA-Experten derzeit noch nicht voraussagen.
Mehrere Faktoren wie etwa Sturm, Wellen und
die Bewegung des umgebenden Meereises spielen
eine Rolle und könnten die Sache beschleunigen.
Sicherheitshalber wurde deswegen jedenfalls
die britische Forschungsstation in der Nähe
geschlossen.
Die Besatzung der “Halley VI” hat die
mobile Station vor kurzer Zeit verlassen.
Dabei gab es schon vor zwei Jahren einen Umzug
auf die angeblich sichere Seite des Risses.
Die Fachleute können das Ganze nur auf sich
zukommen lassen.
Ausgeschlossen ist auch nicht, dass der antarktische
Winter das Schelfeis auch noch einmal eine
zeitlang stabilisieren kann.
Doch welche Gründe gibt es für die Risse?
Auch darauf gibt es keine eindeutigen Antworten,
denn die Details solcher Prozesse sind tatsächlich
noch weitestgehend unbekannt.
Handelt es sich vielleicht doch um ein natürliches
Ereignis?!
Oder bedeutet das alles, dass die Ostantarktis,
die bislang als relativ stabil galt, in Bewegung
gerät?
Dass es dort lange nicht mehr so gut aussieht
wie in der Vergangenheit, hatte vor allem
eine Studie aus dem vergangenen Jahr verdeutlicht.
Insgesamt 44 internationale Organisationen
hatten sich zusammengeschlossen, um den Eisverlust
in der Antarktis zu kalkulieren.
Bis zum Jahr 2012 hatte es demnach durch massiven
Schneefall eine Zunahme der Eismasse in dieser
Region gegeben.
Doch auch das ist jetzt Geschichte.
Denn laut der Studie von 2018 gab es in den
fünf Jahren von 2012 bis 2017 alleine in
dieser Region einen jährlichen Verlust von
28 Milliarden Tonnen Eis.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen: Das Eisschild
der Antarktis hat demnach also seit 1992 also
insgesamt etwa drei Billionen Tonnen Eis verloren.
Mit dieser Menge könnte man ganz Deutschland
rund acht Meter hoch mit Wasser bedecken - eine
unvorstellbare Menge also.
Doch eben nicht nur die reine Wassermenge
alarmiert die Fachwelt.
Sondern eben auch die Geschwindigkeit: 40
Prozent des Eisverlustes passierten der Studie
zufolge in den vergangenen fünf Jahre!
Eis hat ja eine ganz spezielle Eigenschaft,
die es etwa unberechenbar macht.
Die Dichte-Anomalie des Wassers Das Video
anklicken, anschauen und natürlich Bytethinks
abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!